[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thanks so much
I'm Marty Stratton executive producer of
doom eternal Hugo Martin creative
director on doom eternal in 2016 we
launched our reboot of doom and have
been blown away by your support and
excitement for the game thank you in
fact it's a combination of your passion
and our team's love of making doom that
has motivated us to deliver even more so
we're back to announce doom eternal
[Applause]
an awesome awesome new sequel to do for
the past two years it's been so
inspiring to hear you guys talk about
what you'd like to see next and I got to
tell you we're right there with you like
you want the doom Slayer to feel even
more powerful well we got it you want
even more badass demons well there are
twice as many in this game you want to
see hell on earth well we we just teased
it but what we're most excited about is
to show you some of the things that you
might not be expecting
that's right including a ton of features
that we'll have to save for later
because our team will be debuting doom
eternal at QuakeCon this August we'd
love for you to join us live in Dallas
or of course you can tune in online to
catch all the fun but until then we want
to thank everyone who continues to play
doom thanks everyone
thank you
[Applause]